[Music]
on this saturday night
the hotel quarantine nightmare
guests leaving rooms long lineups in the
lobby
it was incredible they were screaming i
thought they were going to lynch the
manager
the pandemonium from the new travel
restrictions
the emergency brake strategy it's
madness
why experts say it's not curbing cases
of kova 19
in ontario plus the final farewell to
the captain
who captured our hearts
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us it's been less than a week since
tight restrictions were put into place
for non-essential travel
travelers who arrive by air are required
to quarantine in a designated hotel for
three days when they land
tonight we are hearing stories of long
waits expensive bills
and little help as jeff semple is about
to show you
guests at the quarantine hotels have
left their rooms
even though the rules indicate they
aren't supposed to
i would call it a boondoggle ray
truesdale knew
this would be a bumpy business trip on
wednesday he arrived from tennessee to
toronto
per canada's new rules he was tested for
kovit 19 on arrival
and quarantined in an airport hotel
pending the results
trewsdale lives with diabetes and says
he was told meals would be delivered to
his room
but after nearly 24 hours he says he
still hadn't received any food
and nobody answers the phone so
i went down to the lobby when i opened
the doors
it was incredible he recorded this video
of hangry
hotel guests
packed in the lobby shouting at staff
they were screaming
i thought they were going to lynch the
manager truesdale eventually received
some toast
and a message that his covid test sample
had been damaged and he needed another
but there's nothing on there that tells
you where what to do
so what do i do who do i contact so
truesdale left his room again
returned to the airport to receive
another test
social media is flooded with similar
accounts from travelers
waiting on hold for hours forced to pay
premium prices with little or no
food we're not trying to punish people
we're trying to keep people
safe in announcing the new measures the
government pointed to concerns of covet
variants arriving from abroad
urging canadians to avoid pandemic
travel
but some insist they have no choice we
had to make the very difficult decision
to go to australia camila pulido just
arrived from down under
visiting her terminally ill
father-in-law she says the processing of
passengers at vancouver's airport was so
disorganized
she had to interact with a dozen
different staff we just couldn't believe
how much risk we had just encountered
like we would have felt so much safer if
we had just come home
i spoke with one woman who arrived here
in toronto last night on a flight with
her family
from pakistan she says that when she
arrived she was told
all the hotels were fully booked and was
instructed to quarantine instead
at home robin jeff sample
in toronto thanks jeff prince edward
island is implementing circuit breaker
measures after reporting six new cases
of cova 19.
the restrictions will last two weeks
starting tomorrow
restaurants will move to take out only
weddings funerals and sports games
will be barred personal gatherings will
be limited to 10 close contacts
events will be restricted to 50 people
new measures are also in place in parts
of nova scotia
to counter a sudden spike in covet 19
infections
restaurants and bars have to close by 10
p.m visitors are restricted at long-term
care homes
sporting events competitions and
cultural performances
will not be allowed the province hopes
the strict rules will
also act as a circuit breaker to stop
the potential spread of a new variant
first detected in the uk ten new cova
cases were reported in the province
yesterday
the largest single day increase in that
province since the beginning of this
year
in ontario the government is pulling the
emergency brake
in two regions thunder bay and simcoe
muskoka are going back into lockdown
because of a rise in those variant cases
that are more transmissible
but as morgan campbell reports health
experts say the
on-again off-again approach isn't
helping this health crisis
i just feel like they're all sitting in
a room with a dart board being like
let's try this one melanie barrett owns
and operates groovy tuesday's bistro in
berry ontario
about 45 minutes north of toronto
frustrated she has been
open for less than two weeks but is now
preparing to shutter once again
we put i would say anywhere between 12
and 15 thousand dollars back into
reopening
stocking my food stocking my wine
stocking my booze
friday the ontario government said it
would be pumping the
so-called emergency break returning
simcoe muskoka
and thunder bay into a full lockdown
those regions are experiencing a spike
in covet 19 cases including
variants as of monday all nonessential
businesses
with the exception of some retail will
be forced to close
these yo-yo effects are really not good
dr gerald evans is the chair of the
division of infectious diseases
at queen's university you do an
effective strong lockdown
wait for vaccine rollout to pop open
and really start to get into the
population when that happens
you'll be able to open and you probably
won't be looking at further closures
words echoed by dr anna banerjee who
believes the provincial color-coded
system
isn't ideal it's confusing and you know
the
the on and off again and closures let's
just get everyone vaccinated
the mayor of bracebridge doesn't believe
his community
should be in lockdown he says
transmission numbers
are low but because his area is part of
simcoe muskoka
he has no choice the potential for what
is happening
in another part of a vast geographic
region to really pull us down too and
sadly this is exactly the way that it is
played out
back in berry barrett is getting ready
to give birth to a baby boy
while hoping her bistro makes it to its
10-year anniversary in june it is just
the weight of the world at this stage as
of monday seven regions will move into
different levels of the province's
reopening plan the two largest areas
toronto
and peel which is made up of both
brampton and mississauga
will remain under a stay-at-home order
until at least
march 8. morgan campbell global news
toronto
in the u.s there's been an uptick in
cases a sign that new variants are
taking hold
today the fda approved the johnson and
johnson covid 19 vaccine
it only requires a single dose and it'll
add to the vaccine arsenal
but as jennifer johnson reports
america's top doctor
is telling americans to take whatever
shot they can
as america's coven 19 death toll climbs
over 510 thousand
johnson johnson's vaccine has been given
federal emergency approval
the company says it's ready to send out
three to four million doses next week
20 million by the end of march good news
is millions of americans search to find
a vaccine i feel like i'm finally
able to take a deep breath this isn't
just a step for me but also the sweet
little kiddos that are in my class
the j j vaccine is one dose instead of
two like pfizer biontech and modernis
but federal health officials are urging
americans not to wait for it and take
any shot they can
get vaccinated the vaccine that's
available to you
get that vaccine that message comes as
the centers for disease control and
prevention
is reporting an alarming increase in new
coven 19 cases
after seeing dramatic drops the cdc
fears the uptick
is coming from new variants first found
in other countries we are watching these
concerning data very closely to see
where they will go over the next few
days the johnson johnson vaccine has
been very effective fighting the new
variants
moderna is currently working on a
booster shot while about 1.4 million
vaccines are now being administered
today
doctors are warning people not to let
their guard down like what happened at
this
maskless party in utah saying the next
two months could be tough
beware the ides of march beginning of
april this is this is going to be a game
changer
the variant first detected in the uk
currently makes up one in five new cases
in florida
as the state braces for an onslaught of
spring breakers
miami beach police say they'll take no
chances vacation responsibly or you will
be arrested
meanwhile some good news for americans
hit hard by the pandemic
the house passed president joe biden's
1.9 trillion dollar coveted rescue
package
the plan provides billions for reopening
schools small businesses local
governments and vaccine production the
bill now goes to the senate
the people of this country have suffered
far too much for too long
we need to relieve that suffering the
president is pushing hard to get the
bill passed by both houses in congress
because extended unemployment benefits
for millions of americans
run out in mid-march jennifer johnson
global news
washington new zealand's largest city is
heading back into lockdown for seven
days
a single case of kova 19 has surfaced
and no one knows
where it came from starting early sunday
morning auckland's 1.7
million residents are only allowed to
leave their homes for essential shopping
and work
health officials are looking at whether
the case is connected to a cluster of
the uk variant
identified in auckland two weeks ago
during his meeting with prime minister
justin trudeau this week
u.s president joe biden made the
strongest statement yet
from an american president about the
fate of michael spavor
and michael kovrick the two canadians
have spent more than 800 days in custody
in china
biden says he'll work with canada on
getting them released
our mercedes stephenson spoke with
kavrik's wife about whether she believes
the president's comments
are more than just words mercedes
robin veena najibullah described the
pledge by biden as powerful
and says it left her feeling that he
understands the heavy price her husband
michael kovrig and fellow canadian
michael spavor have paid over the last
two years
hearing president biden say those words
was really
emotional having him refer to michael
and to michael sfavor by name to call
for their release
was moving um i i really felt that um
his words that human beings are not
bargaining chips
are powerful and and what i took away
from that
is that president biden has
compassion for the unjust suffering that
our michael and michael spauber
are going through as well as that he
understands that canada has been paying
a really high price since
it accepted the extradition request from
the u.s
two years ago beijing seized coverage in
spavor in december
2018 just a few days after canada
arrested huawei cfo
mung wang zhou at the behest of the
united states
with which canada has a long-standing
extradition treaty
chinese officials have repeatedly made
public comments
linking the detention of the two
michaels with the arrest of hmong
who is fighting extradition to the usa
najibullah described
that public commitment as really
significant and said that she hopes to
see action
i hope that our government will seize
this moment
and will work very closely and urgently
with the biden team to translate those
important words
into action so that michaels are in fact
free
now jabula said that there's a new
urgency
to find a solution to bring the two
michaels home
and that the longer they are held in
jail the harder it will be to navigate
the canada-china relationship
tune in for the full interview on the
west block as well as the latest on the
bombshell revelations
regarding allegations of sexual
misconduct
at the highest levels of the canadian
armed forces
robin mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
in nigeria 27 teenaged boys who were
abducted from school last week
are now home they were released just
hours after another kidnapping in the
same region
police say gunmen took over 300 girls
from a boarding school
in a raid friday night it's believed
some girls are being held in a forest
nearby kidnapping for ransom has become
a thriving industry
in this part of the world
police in myanmar are cracking down yet
again on pro-democracy demonstrators
hundreds were arrested at one point
police fired tear gas instead of stun
grenades
there are reports at least one protester
was shot
adding to the political turmoil the
country's envoy to the united
nations was fired for declaring loyalty
to the ousted government
of aung san tsuchi and calling on world
powers to get the military
to relinquish power by any means
necessary
it's been nearly 10 weeks since canada's
v day
when the first cova 19 vaccines arrived
that day has finally come
for africa kovacs the global initiative
aimed at providing vaccine to countries
in need sent the first shipments to the
continent but as crystal commansing
explains
it's the first step on a complicated
path to make sure
no country is left behind
precious cargo for the ivory coast on
board this flight more than 500
000 doses of the astrazeneca vaccine
produced at the serum institute
of india unicef is responsible for
moving the sponsored vaccine to
countries in need around the globe
benjamin schreiber is the project lead
we are
super delighted to starting and rolling
things out we've been
building this for the last year
every day in the coming weeks you will
see new shipments leaving
the very first kovac sponsored shipment
in the world
landed in ghana wednesday the second in
neighboring cote d'ivoire friday where
the health minister was on hand to watch
the historic
unloading a vaccine
speaking on the tarmac he championed the
democratic management
of the pandemic rollout of the vaccine
through kovacs has been slower than
planned
50 million doses had been promised to
africa this month
but until this week none had been
delivered kovacs has relied on the
cooperation of wealthier nations such as
canada
and the united states the u.s initially
refused to participate but last week
president joe biden committed
4 billion dollars to the efforts now the
world health organization is running a
campaign with the hashtag
vaccine equity and support healthcare
workers
it's asking more countries to sign a
declaration with the aim of
every country getting shots into the
arms of healthcare workers
and those most at risk within the first
100 days of the year
dr kate o'brien is a canadian physician
and the director for immunizations
vaccines and biologicals for the who
the loss of a health care worker in a
low income
setting because of illness or heaven
forbid for
severe illness or death means that
tens of thousands of people are going
without any health care
because of the loss of an individual
health care worker we're going to have
to work very hard now in the rollout
and again look at it with an equity lens
to make sure that no one is left behind
kovacs is set to deliver 2 billion doses
to more than 90 low
and middle-income countries by the end
of this year
crystal gamansen global news london
a private service was held today for a
man who did his duty as a soldier
and served as a symbol of hope and
strength during this pandemic
it was only fitting that a plane from
the second world war flew
over captain sir tom moore's funeral
service soldiers then honored him with a
military gun salute
sir tom was a veteran of that war
serving in asia for the british military
because of pandemic restrictions just
eight members of his immediate family
attended i
am so proud of you
what you achieved
your whole life
and especially in the last year
you may be gone
by your message and your spirit lives on
sir tom single-handedly raised tens of
millions of dollars for britain's
healthcare workers by walking laps in
his backyard
he always had a positive attitude please
remember
tomorrow will be a good day became his
trademark motto
the 100 year old died earlier this month
after testing positive for covet 19.
this same unforgiving virus he did so
much to fight
still ahead a holocaust survivor's
decades-long search for a lost
friendship
you might want to grab a box of tissues
for tonight's episode of global's the
new reality because you'll likely fall
in love with its main character
she's a 91 year old holocaust survivor
whose story starts with a cherished bond
during 1930s nazi germany
and wraps up over eight decades later
with a zoom call
our mike armstrong has been calling it a
friendship
interrupted mike well robin this story
is incredibly unlikely and equally
unforgettable we met betty gribenshikov
in florida she grew up in berlin in the
1930s and
jewish what that meant was as she got
older she watched her freedom
stripped away year after year by the
late 1930s when betty was seven and
eight years old
jews in germany weren't allowed in parks
or on beaches
they weren't even allowed to ride
bicycles it was very
gradual the whole thing was very gradual
you know the hitler youth kids were out
there
they used to be my friends they lived
right around where we lived in the same
apartment building one day you're
playing with them
one day and the next day they call me a
dirty jew
what that meant was the friends she had
were important her best friend was a
little
girl anna marie warrenberg they did
everything together
except escape from nazi germany but he
got out with her family before the war
and spent 82 years wondering what
happened to her best friend
she talked about anna marie wrote about
her and brought her up every chance she
got
i don't know whatever happened to her
she probably died in the war
as the mission can now the odds were
against that mystery ever being solved
the odds that would have a happy ending
even less likely
but it would be worth watching to see
who betty's facetiming
on this park bench this is a story we
were very
lucky to tell that's tonight on the new
reality
robin looking forward to it thanks mike
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm robin gill tonight
your canada is the aurora borealis in
alberta's mykolon lake
provincial park thanks for watching good
night
[Music]
you